a thing that I find very fascinating
about one piece is the way it portrays
morality compared to other mangas
especially in Shonen manga despite the
obvious efforts of some authors there is
a clear line between good and evil and
in characters that are meant to be in a
morally gray zone usually end up on one
end of the spectrum sooner or later the
decisive factor for this are often the
moral values these characters hold and
most fights are based on clashes between
morally good and morally bad ideologies
a reliable example for this might be
boku no hero academia the manga is based
on the conflict between heroes that are
trying to protect their good values and
the villains who follow their own
twisted and bad ideologies what stands
out at the center of such storytelling
is the clear opposition of good and evil
in the individual convictions of
characters the ultimate display of this
being the fight of all might against all
for one such stories make it relatively
easy and clear to pick which side is the
morally right and which is the morally
wrong but while there are many mangas of
this kind that you can easily consider
as great one piece does something
different even if it feels slightly
counterintuitive at first glance from
the back of your head it surely enough
feels like the stories also build upon a
conflict of good versus bad ideologies
but if I told you to take a moment and
come up with a character that holds
purely evil values in the sense that
their goal is actually to do evil how
many characters could you actually come
up with there's actually a strong
argument that this number would actually
be very close to zero because in fact
the Wampus world does not have a
Voldemort or so on that seek dominion
over all and now you might think well
what about Blackbeard but what actually
is his ideology simple Blackbeard values
and aims for the exact same thing as our
main character Luffy freedom and freedom
in itself surely is not a concept that
most people would deem as morally wrong
in fact all major players in one piece
hold ideals that cannot be put into two
categories like wrong or good by
themselves Luffy and Blackbeard price
freedom above all else the Marines value
order and justice and white beat values
family none of these ideals are
fundamentally evil but they still come
into conflict with each other now
what I'm describing here is the concept
of moral pluralism basically it says
that people aren't simply good or bad
based on the ideal stay hold and the
different ideologies can morally be
acceptable and still contradict each
other this applies to our world as well
where we often tend to look down on
people who share opposite views and
ideals than us and mark them is bad and
ignorant right from the start this view
of morality is what makes one piece so
different from many other stories now
based on this it might make you wonder
if the argument here is that there's
actually no good or no evil in one piece
but that's not the case in fact not
seeing someone like Blackbeard or kind
of as evil would render the whole plot
of the story meaningless so the argument
here much rather is that ODIs
understanding of good and evil is not
based on values and ideals but rather on
something different so let's try this
let's look at a few examples the Marines
in general value order and justice this
ideology is interpreted very differently
by very different people while the likes
of garb and Sengoku see it as their duty
to protect the innocent and the weak by
being gentle and respectful and trying
to be genuine even in the treatment of
their enemies a kind of an Lucci
slaughter and destroy knowledge in order
to keep the very same ideal both the
white beard pirates and the donkey heart
pirates value family over everything but
while white beard views all of his crew
equally as his children and will go to
any lengths to protect them the
flamingos gave a kind of hierarchy to
his subordinates and while his system as
family he also sees it as his right to
make use of them to his benefit lastly
let's take a look at Luffy and
Blackbeard both follow the ideologies of
freedom and dreams both have a very
similar crew and yet Luffy wants to
share this dream with his crew and help
those in need
while black bead uses these ideals as a
justification to murderers on crewmate
and slaughter his way through the grand
line with the worst people imaginable as
such it is not a coincidence that there
are so many parallels between the two
characters now what these examples
should help illustrate is that good or
evil do not come from values that people
hold but rather from the way they
interpret and act upon them the way you
affect those around you by trying to
reach your ideals is what really
determines the morality of a person to
Oda this is what makes Blackbeard such a
unique villain
what makes one piece such a fascinating
story compared to other mangas now I
would like to hear your opinion on this
matter what do you think makes a
character good or bad and other
characters with truly evil ideals in one
piece and what do you think for example
about Kaito is his ideal and goal
revenge is it death and would that be
morally wrong to strive for share your
thoughts on this admittedly very
philosophical topic in the comments
below if you liked this video don't
forget to like share and subscribe to be
notified for any future content of mine
or dislike don't share and unsubscribe
it's a free world people I hope this
year on next time and until then have a
great week
[Music]
[Music]